pavels luca meine damen und herren ihr
seht ist bereits im titel eingeblendet
wir erwarten heute youtuber das ist
kilian ort für zeiten
ich habe hier oben ist ein riesenkicker
nicht hin zoomen wie willst du das ganze
erklären
[Musik]
ich habe halt gar keinen plan geht auf
jeden fall sagen dass max
nein das ist eine rolex die erträge ich
gar keinen plan b ist für einen
tippgeber ein kleiner tipp absolut
weiter vor welche nie drauf gekommen
piloten ich wollte es gerade sagen immer
diese dunkle karotten vereinfacht
[Musik]
nein auf keinen fall
nein natürlich kannst du deine eigene
ist keine ahnung
ein bisschen aus wie ich also ja das war
es irgendwie somit ich hatte nur noch
ein gedacht hätte freundin die auf
youtube mal ich werde niemals drauf
gekommen
julia blutig ich dazu nicht sagen wie es
euch das vorschläge müssten wäre ich
nicht drauf gekommen
ich hätte eher shirin oder so gesagt ich
bin hat schon öfter von instagram
gewesen deswegen alles klar
die 228 weiter mit dem nächsten bild tim
gabel
nein da treten zu vier ringe macht egal
seit kenntlich werde ich nehme mir punkt
raus also die katze wurde haben in den
punkt da ich hier bin trotzdem trotzdem
ansage des gewinns gottfried
elano kennst du dich aber krass ich habe
nur diese videos gesehen mit justin
immer also diese reaktionäre trainings
zu kantig als souverän punkt das hat
immer im auto
max das sind da das sind doch dinge sehr
oft restlos oder halo kids mein gott ich
wollte gerade sah ich war so moritz aber
danach zu nicht so breit machte der
trickski wie jeans
tim gabel wenig hängen
ich hab jetzt immer so gemacht seine
handwerk machen du bist doch das nur
noch wenig kohle da ist
deutsche sind immer noch 13 deutsche
youtube
sany lux dagegen hast mir ja das ging
jetzt nicht denken dass irgendwie das
mitleben haben und dass man einmal daten
da wenn man dann packt
deswegen will ich immer das sagen
ich war ein party lectra okay jetzt
direkt raus
ich weiß es ist niemand weil sein team
warten dass sich einmal überlegen ich
dass wir sagen es ist jugendband nein
ich weiß wie es ist toni kroos kennst du
ja weg
kein lob ok alles oder nichts
alles oder nichts das gerät hat gewonnen
andré und ich konnte endlich einen
partner werden wir haben hier ja auch
ein video aufgenommen
da müssen auch wir schauen wir da
gewonnen ich würde das nicht erst jetzt
auf jeden fall nennt euch gefallen hat
danke übrigens anderen zweite hinter der
kamera
wenn euch das video gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen oder und wir sehen
uns dann anders wieder deuce
[Musik]